-We have something in common.
We both --
-Just one thing.
-Only one thing.
[ Laughter ]
-Just one.
-I know. Pick one of the many
things we do have in common.
We both drive trucks.
-When did you get a truck?
-I got a truck --
I got a Ford F-150.
I've had it now
probably 10 years now.
-What?
-Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah.
I have a picture.
This is my --
This is my Ford --
This things is unbelievable.
-You drive a truck?
-Oh, yeah.
I like it.
It's like blue
and, like, kind of khaki pants.
It looks like
it works at Best Buy.
-So, wait -- khakis.
[ Laughter ]
It looks like
it works at Best Buy.
-Wait. Do you name --
Did you name your truck?
-You know,
I was gonna name it...
-What?
-...but I ended up not doing it.
Yeah, I didn't name it.
-That's rude.
-Let me see --
-I have a truck.
I have a truck.
Yours is really cute.
[ Laughter ]
This is a --
This is a real truck.
This is an F-250.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-F-250?
-Yes.
-Let me see that thing.
-But your --
But your little F-150
looks adorable.
Did it come
with a remote control?
[ Laughter ]
-What do you do with it?
That's gin--
-No. I -- It is ridiculous,
because here's the thing.
I had it at my ranch in Montana,
and it made sense there.
You know, use it for things.
But then I took it
for a while to L.A., and --
But I will say,
what reminds me of your truck
is, whenever I pulled up
at "The Voice," Blake has a cute
little truck like you, too.
[ Laughter ]
I pulled up next to his,
and he's, like, giant,
and his is, like, smaller.
-It was tiny.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, and I'm like 5'3 1/2",
and I'm like, I'm getting out...
-Yeah.
[ imitates truck horn ]
-Anyway, I felt powerful.
Her name is Betty White,
so, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Betty White.
That's a great one, by the way.
-Her name is Betty.
Why did you originally
get a truck?
-I wanted -- I wanted to bring
pumpkins to my house from --
[ Laughter ]
When it's, uh --
It was pumpkin season,
so there was, like, pumpkins.
I didn't want to put pumpkins
in a car, in a thing,
so I got a truck.
-Got some first-world problems.
[ Laughter ]
-I've only use it
like once a year.
-I guess I should get a Hummer
because I need pumpkins.
[ Laughter ]
That's awesome.
-I had to transport
the pumpkins.
-That's me, too.
I got it for Lowe's.
-Yeah, understood.
See?
We have more things in common.
-They're so comfortable.
I want to take a road trip
just so I can be in it.
-Me too.
I love a good sound system.
-Yes.
-The whole thing is great.
I want to talk about
"The Voice."
-Yes.
-I hear you guys are coming back
with brand-new judge...
-Ariana.
-...Ariana Grande.
-Yeah!
It's so good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
-How are you guys?
Are you gelling?
Are you bonding?
-We're -- Are you gellin'?
I'm gellin'.
The commercial.
Anyway...
No, I love her.
We'd actually run into
each other a couple times
before, but not really, like,
you know, been able to,
like, talk.
And she's so funny.
-She is funny.
-Like, very witty.
-Yeah.
-Like, in the beginning,
even, like, behind the scenes,
like, she wasn't, like,
using a lot of her material
she could've used out there,
and then I feel like
slowly towards the knockouts --
Like, we've already taped
everything up to the lives,
and she's hysterical.
Like, very witty.
And very -- We've never
had a coach like her.
I've only been there
for eight seasons but, like,
in all my seasons,
I've never heard a coach
talk about vocal health as much.
And I'm like, "I guess we should
have mentioned that."
[ Laughter ]
-We are called "The Voice."
-We're all, like, vocalists.
Like, no one's ever mentioned
it, and she's really into it.
So, it's cool.
And everybody vibes so well.
It's good.
-How is it
to film with a live audience?
-Great!
So that's -- Oh, my God.
This is funny.
So, we all have to --
Now that we're back
with a live audience --
we haven't been, I feel like,
in a couple seasons,
two or three --
and when we walk out,
they have the coaches
walk out separately.
-Yeah.
-Like, they have all us walk out
separately and like,
"You know, and John Legend,"
and then we get all of us
or whatever.
Did you like that?
That's dumb.
Anyway...
[ Laughter ]
That was a poor example.
But anyway.
So we're walking out, and I go
out and they're like, "Yay!"
And then John goes out, "Yay,"
and then Ariana goes out,
and it's literally like BTS
has entered the building.
Like, they lose their minds.
-Yeah.
-And then,
Blake has to follow it.
[ Laughter ]
Because they're like --
'Cause they --
He comes out, and they're like
clapping like they were.
But it was like, "Mur mur mur."
[ Laughter ]
[ Sad tuba plays ]
I know Blake was like,
"Could I go before Ariana?
Like, this is embarrassing."
-"I don't want to follow that."
-Yeah.
They literally lost their minds.
-She's -- yeah, yeah.
-It's exciting.
It's gonna be fun to watch.
-Yeah.
-Thank you so much, again,
for coming back to our show.
-And I'm so sorry that I
screwed up all the interview.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And for being here in studio.
We don't need this.
You're the greatest.
-Yeah.
-Kelly Clarkson, everybody!
-This is the truck.
-The new season
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
premieres September 13th,
and the new season
of "The Voice"
returns September 20th.